welcome back to onbase live I am your
host Mookie Betts and today we got 2020
World Series champion and my teammate
[__] Hernandez what's going on brother
how you doing not much enjoying the view
of Lake Erie one of the four Great Lakes
as I was listening to you pre-interview
yeah do you know the four Great Lakes I
don't bro whenever people ask me that
question I said no speak English no from
this country you know no say papi I
didn't know any of them until uh I just
knew there were I didn't know if there
are four I just know that there are
Great Lakes we'll just go out they're
and now I did learn today Lake Erie is
one of them so kids stay in school so
you're in Boston you came back to LA how
have you enjoyed it uh Becca in L.A I
would say home it's been great it's been
great
um once I learned about the trade
um everything happened quick because I
had to be on a flight in like five hours
and I didn't know what to think and got
off the plane at like two in the morning
and I had to be at the field at 8 30 in
the morning the next day yeah
so I didn't really get to
you get to feel much till after that
first game and we had a day off so we
had solid over 24 hours to think about
what just happened and it was it was
really cool it was exciting I hadn't
been back in La since 2020 and uh
I always thought that I was gonna go
back for the first time as a visiting
player and I got to go back wearing
white again which was really cool
nice okay so so take me through the the
process because
you know you're playing and obviously
you're in Boston so
every year they're trying to win
and you're going through and you kind of
see the writing it's kind of on the wall
[__] you know you may get traded
you're probably gonna get traded and
then you eventually do so like yeah take
me through that because people people
don't know what it's not like they just
call you boom you traded you know
sometimes it's kind of like a process I
guess there is sometimes it is
they call you and boom you're traded so
I want to know about your process how
was it yeah
um
kind of went through it last year not
knowing what was going to happen on
certainty last year the deal
um Veterans as you know get traded when
they're on expiring contracts and the
teams aren't doing so well and last year
I figured I was going to get traded
didn't happen I got to go back for one
more year and uh I guess things didn't
go my way uh playing time went a little
bit down and
eventually it became kind of uh I was
the odd man out and my agent started
getting calls and he was like hey man I
think they're shopping you you know uh I
don't want you to like be thinking about
that when you're playing but yeah how
did you not think about that uh well I
got my I got myself thinking one day
during the game like just thinking about
where I was going to end up and I was
not there you know and I was like all
right this needs to stop this is too
much
um
you you maybe Trader you might not be
traded so the only thing you can do is
control what you can and at this moment
is play the game and it became a
distraction for one game and that was
more than enough for me to to tell
myself all right stop every once we're
in we're here we're here you know we
can't think about it if you want to
think about it while you're at home then
go ahead but while we're here we're just
thinking about baseball we're focusing
on today and
um you know it's it's kind of inevitable
sometimes when uh your family reads
things online and they start asking
questions and all and uh
I guess there was like I said a couple
multiple calls with my agent you know
all the teams and stuff and
um found out the Dodgers were yeah what
happened when so what were your thoughts
when you heard the Dodgers are in I was
like man I was like this is weird
um
I didn't really know what to think I
didn't think that it was going to happen
you know it was just one of those things
one of those teams you know checking
boxes calling and trying to find out
what was what was what and
um the day that it happened and it just
came to Fresh fruition and we uh we had
it we didn't have BP that day and uh
they told me about two o'clock and
they're like hey this trade is happening
it's in the one year line we want you to
hear from us we don't want you to hear
from the media
[Music]
um
and then I went back out
the media is still in the locker room so
I can't clear my locker yeah because the
media is there they don't know anything
yet
um so I just hung out with my
still teammates at the time and uh we
had we had a little gathering little
event happening in the weight room that
day somebody lost a bet so that thing
went through and allowed the media to
clear the the locker room and once it
was time I had to pick up my my locker
that had three years of belongings
figure out what I needed for the next
week or so figure out what I need to
ship home what I need to ship to LA and
then got to go home and so it wasn't too
bad it was it wasn't too bad you got you
got
told in enough time and it wasn't and
you were going back to LA which
I mean if you were going to get traded I
mean I guess that's a good place to good
place to come right yeah for sure I mean
I think you know obviously expiring deal
you know you want to like have your like
personal Market go up or whatever right
when it comes to free agency but I still
I still care about winning more than
anything and I want to be in a place
where I'm where I'm going to win
um and for me you know getting traded to
La was probably the best case scenario
uh going back to the familiarity uh
working with hitting coaches that knew
me uh
you know the little things trainers
coaching staff all those things uh
clubhouse guys like they're all the same
so I knowing everybody is is is huge
when it comes to to
uh change of scenery yeah uh it's the
second time I get traded in season and
the first time I didn't know a single
person and that that's on the team and
that was rough it was rough because
you're trying to learn the new team
you're trying to learn Personnel every
single teammate of yours and it's just
you know it
when you're not yourself when you feel
yourself you don't feel like you can
produce the same way and you got to go
play so you're uncomfortable and uh for
me being able to go back a different
group of guys but there's at the same
time still like half of the guys yeah
I've played with the other half I've
played against them so it's not like I
had to come in and get to know 25 other
guys so right that that part was made it
made it easy
okay so there's this game called on base
off base in or out
and play with you
the first thing is
serious engagement photos or your inner
out on those uh I am beyond out Beyond
out so tell me about tell me about these
engagement photos that you took how it
came about you know nothing not much you
do is serious and that's not a knock or
anything it's just you just you love
having fun you love laughing you love
joking and so knowing that you took
silly engagement photos is
the perfect depiction of [__] Hernandez
so tell me about him
all right we live in a social media era
right
everything has to be a nice photo shoot
to post and do it for the clout and all
that you gotta look all cute and [__]
and
we got engaged I told my wife
we're not taking engagement photos like
I don't I don't like looking at the
camera and like trying to look pretty
and all that like I don't that's not my
type of photo shoot that [__] makes me
uncomfortable
one day we're watching a movie called
masterminds
we see these like this couple Zach
elephanakis and I forget the name of the
the girl she's a she's in Saturday Night
Live and they get engaged in the movie
and they take this
photo shoot as we recreated it in this
and these pictures and that's awesome I
tell my wife I was like hey
if you want to do those pictures I'll do
those engagement pictures thinking
there's no way she's gonna say yes
I married her for a reason right yeah
she said yes I'm all in and sure enough
we found the most absurd uh outfits that
we could find as close to the movie as
possible and we reached out to a
photographer when the photographer heard
about the idea she could not be more
stoked so that is all we went to a
random Park in Arizona and we took these
beautiful super serious beautiful
engagement pictures and so
that's what you used
to send out to people like Hey we're
getting saved the dates did you put that
on the same oh no yeah people already
knew this was for uh for the Instagram
clout oh this is just for Instagram it
wasn't like send out or anything yeah I
mean we we I think we used them here and
there for other reasons but uh
yeah I know that was to to let the world
know you know that picture right there
yeah this is this is the couple of the
century that's the thing of beauty yeah
shout out to you appreciate it that was
awesome Okay so
on base off base you personally have the
greatest wind up in MLB history
are you on base or off base on that I'm
on base
um I will say it doesn't it doesn't
correlate with my record or my era
but
I mean the mechanics you can deny them
they look awesome so when you got the
pitch before before you even got up
there and you're leading it up and you
see the the writing on the wall like you
may have the pitch what was going
through your head well you know when
position players get to pitch especially
for the first time yeah the occasion is
very different
it's usually a Blog
I am playing second base this game and
I am I had just gotten back from The
Dugout and I am oh for seven
okay so you were over that means the
Extra Inning game oh we are in the
top of the 16th inning oh it got out of
hand
and the game is tied the game is tied
and you're pitching okay we run out of
Bullpen arms okay
Dave Roberts
looks at me and goes hey
score
you're bitching
I say I'm sorry what
it's like yeah you're in
and look out of the bullpen and Ridge
Hill is getting loose
um chill is like rapidly getting loose
any you know at the time he was he was
in 80 yeah he was like 62. and uh you
know it takes him a while and he starts
going and I guess he was going to pitch
if we took the lead but if it stayed
tight it was up to us up to me and then
I had like five people come up to me and
they're like do not don't you dare start
throwing hard you know just lob it
whatever and uh my hardest is racing I'm
not listening to anybody I'm like give
me police the score run what's so you
know like I haven't so you didn't really
want to pitch
in a tied game
yeah just in general I mean no I wanted
a pitch in a blowout okay you're right
not in a tight game that's a nerve
record because then you feel like you
lose the game
yeah
and you know I go out there first pitch
I throw I get Nick Williams to like ball
got in on him a little bit and in my
head I'm like this well this mound looks
way closer to the plate than the plate
looks from the mountain I was like I
feel like I'm gonna hit this dude's
helmet whenever I release the ball I
feel that close first pitch it gets in
on him but I haven't been in a mound in
I don't know 20 years ball gets hit in
the Gap and I think it's a [__] tank
I look back and Bellinger's running out
they're like a dinosaur like in the Gap
full extension gets it I'm like oh man
one for one let's go this is easy
next guy I can't throw a strike
walking next guy walking
and then we get to Trevor plouffe so two
walks two walks one out running first
and second Trevor ploof of the plate
I get him on two strikes I don't know
how we got there
and then I throw him an eephis
um which had a chance to catch me in the
corner maybe maybe it did maybe it
didn't and he has money grindel clanks
it I don't get the call strike and I'm
like man I made my pitch I use my best
pitch the ephus now I don't know what to
do
next pitch I throw at like 80 percent
it was like a pitch out it was in the
other batter's box and Trevor plouffe
just
absolutely launches this baseball we're
in Philly
and the ball lands almost in like in the
bullpen over the stands you know it can
go in the bullpen by center field but
then there's stands yeah and it has to
go over the stands to get in the bullpen
the ball almost goes in there walk off
three run Homer hmm at least it was like
quick though you didn't have to like
stay out there for a while I know the
walk to the dog I felt like forever
though and then I get in that locker
room
and you can hear people thinking it is
so quiet you can hear what people
thinking
and I sit in my locker and I'm like man
this is by far the worst game in the
history of baseball for on a personal
level yep but I can't even be mad no
I got to experience this so I
don't know how far you really were mad
at is the oh for seven right so I opened
my like nobody's saying a word nobody
knows how to feel we gotta this is like
two in the morning we got a game at noon
the next day
and I just go
hey guys
has any of you ever gone over seven at
the plate and lost the game on the mound
everybody started laughing nobody cared
anymore
true story though that year we had to
play a game 163. it was there because
the division was tied so all because we
could have potentially lost the division
because I got on the mountain in a tie
game hey but it's all right though you
make you're just making history only
position player ever to give up a
walk-off Homer humble brag even more
humble brag only two guys to go over
seven of the plate and lose the game on
the mound
me and Babe Ruth
not many people can be on the list it's
you and Babe Ruth that's a list of two
that's hard to make good luck show hey
all right so one more I got one more
what about on base off base the Dodgers
uniforms
or more clap are more classic than the
Red Sox I think that's on base I think
the Dodger white is the best uniform in
base I think it's the most classic
uniform in baseball I agree I love
putting it on not even just because it's
the Dodgers in San Diego it's just the
uniform is just dope it's a good fit
it's hard for that uniform to not look
on something look good on somebody and
you can wear it many different ways many
different colors whatever you want oh I
know about that yeah yeah I got about
eight different set of pants
yeah all right so we're going back to
Boston in a couple days
and how do you think it'll feel for you
going back ah like a little weird it'll
be a little weird but not as weird as
going back to LA I feel like it took me
almost three years to go back to LA and
it's only gonna take me like three weeks
to go back to Boston so you know getting
it out of the way quick is kind of like
a good feeling and uh I'm looking
forward to it because everything
happened so quick I didn't get to say
bye to everybody yeah yeah so it'd be
good to get some closure so yeah and
then this will be my first time going
back and since 2019. I'm really nervous
like I'm really nervous and not
necessarily uh
it's more more just that I haven't been
back in so long it's like where I grew
up and I don't know what to expect you
know
um hopefully it's cool though I think I
think it'll be fun you know I'm gonna go
in there and see the clubhouse you know
and there's a the clubhouse is new a lot
of new things a lot of new faces
um you know I'm more excited to see the
people though the people are what what I
remember the most you know they uh made
the the most of the experience so
um you got any advice for me bro
I think you're gonna love it man I think
they're gonna you're gonna be filled
with love
um the locker room is nice the visiting
locker room you've known Brennan never
been not so nice Okay but the home new
side is is nice
um I I can tell those fans love you bro
they still do they I saw a lot of number
50 jerseys still every day so uh you
know they
they miss you bro you did a lot for that
team yeah it was cool it was cool we'll
see how it plays out so but you had a
bobble head
that came but then you got traded but
they still gave out the bobble head and
there was a note right you had a sticky
note what did it say how did that come
about
uh it was kind of what I among the words
of that I used during my uh Instagram
post that I got to you know put into
words during the flight to LA and uh
Raquel reached out to me oh nice okay
and um she was like Hey [__] you know
still crying
yep we have this bobblehead coming up is
it okay for you to that if we still give
it out it's not a Red Sox bobblehead
it's a WBC bobblehead and I was like
yeah absolutely I mean how many
bobbleheads do you have and she's like 8
500. I was like all right well I don't
need 8 500 for my family no you don't I
just need a little box so I can take
care of my family my loved ones and
they're gonna love this bobblehead
because it's got the WBC uniform on and
uh yeah you got my blessing and she
asked if I wanted to to write anything
and I was like yeah I would love for you
to say like thank you to all the fans
and to the city and everybody and
um those are years that are always going
to be special in my heart because you
know it's if I was in a man at 29 years
old because
I'm at an age where I should be a man
then having a baby is what started
making me become a man and
um that is that's those are the the
years and the memories that you'll never
forget about it's just you know seeing
your baby grow up in a city that is just
it just adds that much that much more to
it what about do you have any anything
off the field that happened in Boston
like uh you know
I I don't know maybe did you do on the
duck boat rides or anything like that
any history because a lot of history no
I didn't I uh first year was still we
were still like in the middle of covid
the pandemic and with the newborn and
all that like I we didn't do much we
stayed right across the street from the
stadium and uh
and last year in 2022 I got hurt which
so I didn't get to travel with the team
for like two months and that as hard as
that was physically mentally I got to
spend a lot of time with the family and
we got to you know walk around Boston a
lot I uh
if I had to go back and do it all again
I would probably do more like
touristy stuff as far as like getting to
know the city a little more but at the
same time I loved I loved living in
Boston I we lived in Back Bay I loved
being able to I didn't grow up with this
in Puerto Rico like being able to walk
everywhere that was that was really cool
to me that was I was able to you know
just go grab breakfast with a family or
whatever dinner on Day games things like
that that was that was pretty cool and
then so then obviously now you're back
in LA and yeah I think you had mentioned
you didn't realize you had needed to
change another change of senior year or
whatever it is
as bad as you did and so what what was
it why did you why do you feel like you
needed it so bad well
um I was when I was talking about that I
was talking about like playing in front
of the LA fan base again but to me like
I was having by far the worst like year
of my career like
for many reasons and
um you know you you have this mentality
you can have this mentality of all right
the season starts today and I try to do
that every single day but it's hard when
you're in the same place every day and
one way or another you're reminded of
what's going on yeah and especially in
Boston yeah especially in Boston so once
I get traded I like all right I'm in a
new team like whatever happened in
Boston doesn't matter anymore because
they haven't seen it like it hasn't been
with this uniform on like
this is a this is my opportunity to like
literally start over and nothing matters
from what half the only thing that
matters is what happens from this moment
on
and I guess going coming to the new team
is what allowed me to change my
mentality and then on the other side
like I didn't get to play in front of
this fan these fans in 2020 right
knowing that it was going to be my last
year in LA and uh last game I had played
in front of him was game five of the
nlds in 19 that
it didn't end our way so uh
just coming back and feeling all the
love it's a you know it's been special
uh I played in in uh in a lot of really
loaded rosters yeah and for the fan base
to
lean on like
give that look that type of love to me
like out of all the names on the team
that's something that like it's even
hard to to put into words going back to
2020 because that was a crazy year
obviously with covet and all this stuff
and
during the World Series run when we
stayed in one room for a month straight
like tell me about that whole how much
you enjoyed that because that you were
you were with those guys for how many
years six six years and so
you guys finally got
I guess you got into the World Series in
17 but like you smelled it now right we
we can really win
we're gonna we're gonna win and so how
how was that going through
um you know the bubble and uh that whole
process
because it was it's definitely different
than 17 when you were in the World
Series and everything the world was
normal right 17 we lose
fortunate events 18 where you ran into
this
machine yeah that was a pretty good team
yeah and then 19 we're supposed to win
we got the best team in baseball again
then we go out there and we win like 106
games and then we go on the first round
so 2020 it was like there was a couple
of us that knew that was it for us as
Dodgers it was our last chance
um
and we looking at it on paper after we
acquired you we're like we got to do it
this year if we don't do it this year
it's you know the window doesn't last
forever even though we're in probably
one of the greatest if not the greatest
franchise in baseball right now minor
league system is loaded so like we have
it since it'll be good for a really long
time like this is it for like this might
be it for this group that we've had for
a long time and uh
that was by far my favorite postseason
out of like the seven including the one
where I went off in Boston like to be
able to like as a group be together for
a full month
because like in a regular postseason
home games Everybody Plays the game and
then everybody goes home on the road
everybody goes to the same spot but then
everybody goes their own several ways
everybody's got family like so everybody
just wants to go back into the room with
their families
in the bubble we had our families but we
were the hotel was just was open just
for us so it was like we're all just we
were hanging out and we're running
during during the uh day we all go to
the field early
to go eat
and then after the game we were all
hanging we're all hanging up and then
days off we're at the hotel together all
day long so like to be able to
experience that for a full month the
whole group together getting to go
through like all the ups and then
Atlanta going down being down three to
one so like going through all those
emotions together as a group and not
like the same way you would go through
it together as a group if you were in
all hanging out yeah 24 7. I think that
added a little more to it and
probably the chemistry that we had that
year was what allowed us to to come back
from down three to one I would also say
not having days off and exploiting that
Bullpen helped a little bit but uh you
know that's what allowed us to to come
back from that and then once we come
back from down three to one there's no
way
yeah yeah we smell blood then so tell me
about
um that that
during that postseason
you had a moment
against the Padres
and uh
is probably one of your most
embarrassing moments I would assume yeah
and tell me tell me about it tell me how
what happened okay so um
as we leave from LA from beating the
Brewers in the first Wild Card round
that we had that year
um
one of my molars gets infected I had a
root canal Crown gets infected and
I start hurting I talked to the doctor
and I was like Hey My My molar's killing
me man like I have a crown and like it's
killing me for no reason he's like oh
everything you're saying sounds like you
have an infection we'll send you some
antibiotics the only problem is
diarrhea is a side effect and I was like
man like
I have diarrhea every other day it's
fine and
he's like all right well go ahead
sure enough I get I get diarrhea and on
like my third day of being in this
medication we are uh
we're in a big situation we uh I had
come in the game to pinch it for
somebody so I was in the game as a DH
okay out of all the positions I play I
was the Aging so I'm in The Dugout I get
to lead off the next inning so I'm like
full like elbow guard batting gloves I
don't have my helmet on because it's not
a time yet whatever we're on defense and
uh
we punch out I think it was it was uh D
May was pitching I think we punched out
Manny to get out of the inning and I let
go of it yeah [__] yeah those emotions
made me like make my body like push you
know because I'm flexing I'm excited
and a little four comes out okay I'm
like oh [__] I think I just [__]
punch my ass real quick I think I just
[__] so were you were you were you at
this point were you concerned or you
were like you know what I gotta go don't
even I had to lead off the inning that
was the third out there was no time it
was either that or tell doc hey Doc I
can't go take me out
can't say that if I'm not dying I'm not
getting into that game yeah okay
sure enough I go to a plate
uh my lower half is a little more
slippery than usual a little squishy
and uh did that help it did not help at
all man like
we all know I have some trouble focusing
on a daily basis and that just did not
allow me to focus I punched out in three
pitches against Garrett Richards I'll
never forget I go on the dug I go in The
Dugout I told doc as I'm walking by like
in front of him in the Dugout after
striking on three pitches in a playoff
game I was like hey dog I just [__] my
pants bro
I don't think he believes me so I go
straight down I take my batting gloves
off I take my helmet I put my bat and I
go running upstairs
and I tell I yell at Alex Alex I think I
need some sliders to this point I
haven't realized we're wearing white yet
I get in the toilet even think about it
no no not even I I just knew my [__] but
I was a gosh I got two pairs of Sliders
they'll hold up you know
I get in the I get in the toilet I take
all my [__] down and I see a big stain a
little more yellow than my shirt
on on the sliders on the sliders I was
like oh [__] I start dying laughing
already I'm already sitting at the
toilet you know I can do whatever I have
to do and not worry about a thing
but then I'm like oh [__] we're wearing
white and I like
put the sliders to the side sure enough
it was on the fan the same stain that is
on my sliders was on the white pants
on National Television
no I threw those out I got two brand new
pairs from Sliders from Alex
I was like Alex I don't know what to do
with his pants but he's like just throw
them there like we'll we'll figure out
how to wash them and I put a different
pair of white pants and uh yeah that was
a story I made it a little longer than
maybe I should have but it was it was
part of the process the story like I
wanted everybody to know what I was
going through and then the spring
training
um
the Red Sox were doing a social media
thing and I was doing it with JT and he
got to ask me what would the most
embarrassing thing that's ever happened
to me on a baseball field and I was kind
enough to share my experience with
people and let let everybody out there
in the world know that we're normal
people and that [__] happens too you
know literally and
um dude wise heard about it dude wipes
dude wipes you gotta you got okay keep
going and they reached out to him they
reached they actually tweeted
hey have your team reach reach out to
our team
and I was like Hey guys like look at
this what are you waiting for reach out
I got I want baby wipes we got a deal
done and we uh
got a lot of baby wipes or dude wipes
not baby wipes and uh I got a little bit
of cash and it's a it's a beautiful you
gotta pay for pooping in your own pants
[__] happens man don't hate the place I
hate the game or the antibiotics I guess
oh yeah or the antibiotic you know
there's a lot of things I would do and
that's not one of them not on purpose at
least
I can't even imagine I'll be sweating I
mean man but yeah bad didn't last long
so oh yeah you're in it I made it fast
you're in and out yeah I wonder I wonder
if anybody saw it like on the Padres I
don't I mean I mean you would probably
it probably thought you sat in some dirt
or something right right
it match their uniforms too
I do yeah
all right so let's go back to early [__]
from Puerto Rico grew up in Puerto Rico
tell me about that like I was playing
ball in Puerto Rico Puerto Rico when you
were younger
um yeah so I try to start playing
baseball when I was four my dad took me
to baseball summer camp and after the
first day I get in the car and he's like
how did it go I was like Dad I don't
want to go back you don't want to go
back the sun is way too hot okay he's
like all right well I guess this is it
[__] all right well good luck in school
you know there goes Sports
two years later I'm six
I start to to fall in love with Ken
Griffey Jr okay and I'm like Dad I want
to play baseball again so I uh my dad
put me found a baseball league for me
right like around my my where we lived
and
um I was on the team the Marlins and
then the Marlins team was not very
competitive and I quickly became the
best player on the team and my dad's
like hey we need to get he needs to keep
improving we need to find another team
so we went to a different League that
had better competition and the team was
also the Marlins so I was doing double
participation and all the time I messed
up uniforms I wore the wrong Marlins
uniform to the game blah blah but uh no
man I mean growing up in Puerto Rico
baseball is definitely a number one
sport
volleyball and basketball right there
behind it soccer is gaining a lot of
popularity but uh baseball is it man did
you play anything else I played
volleyball volleyball play volleyball
beach volleyball or just now it's just
regular all the way to high school and
my dad was like when I got to high
school my dad's like hey man you're
gonna be short
they're gonna be playing volleyball and
if you keep playing you might mess up
your shoulder your best chances of
baseball is um let's let's call it I was
like all right that's fine that works
um was that hard
yeah it was hard it was hard seeing your
school teams suck and you know that
you're better than some of those guys
but you're not allowed to play so that
part sucks but other than that I mean I
think I would say it all worked out yeah
it definitely it definitely worked out
yeah Puerto Rico is a little different
when it comes to baseball than it is in
the states the states is most of it like
most kids play in school and obviously
there's kids that play travel ball and
all that but even if you're playing
travel ball you're still playing at
school
um back home there's so many like it's
so small and there's so many schools in
each town that like it would be
impossible to have competitive baseball
if if there was only like School leagues
so we we don't call it travel ball we
just call it you know baseball normal
baseball yeah but uh that's what we
that's what we did and
um I played in a lot of different teams
a lot of different leagues it was always
about like how how are we getting the
the best competition how are we going to
improve uh my dad has a little bit of a
temper so he would argue with some
people in this league so we would have
to go to a different league and so on so
that's kind of how it went did you play
with any guys that I
I'm trying to thank all the guys from
Puerto I don't even remember all the
guys from Puerto Rico because there are
there are a lot but on the top of my
head I can't remember bro did you play
with any of those guys uh you play with
the WBC right yeah yeah so some of the
like bigger names are younger than me so
I didn't get to play against them like
Korea buys Lindor
um Correa is like three years younger
than me Lindor and Javier closer to my
age but they once they got to like high
school they went to study in Florida
yeah I never got to play against them
um
is way older than me uh I guess Eddie
Rosario I played the same age though
right yeah I played with him on our
senior year we started going to like
perfect game tournaments and stuff okay
and he was in under he was in underclass
and he was the best leader on the team
even though he was getting drafted a
year after all of us they were supposed
to get drafted that year
um I don't know if you remember Alex
Claudio with a bucks funny change up
yeah I played with or against him since
we were like eight years old oh so
that's like that's one of your homeboys
like you've known him forever Christian
Vasquez I play with vaski when I was
seven he was eight okay he had the same
size he does now
uh I play with some of those guys
growing up but uh for the most part we
didn't start playing together like
against each other till what like high
school already but uh seen definitely
seen some of those guys that you grew up
playing with or against it's to be in
the league it's it's really cool and
then you got drafted I got drafted in
2009 17 year old by the Astros Astros
then you bounced around a couple times
right I uh got drafted in 09. and you
play with JD then
we play we got drafted the same year we
never played on the same team we did a
bunch of instructs and mini camps and
stuff together
um but I was a I think he was a
four-year senior I was a high school
senior so I was 17 he was already 21
yeah and JT like he's like just cruised
through the mileage system
um
you could tell from the first instructs
he like he was in the hallway harder
than everybody else he was way more
advanced than than we were at the time
and
um you know you could always tell that
he was
especially he had it he's right right so
you know from the early on from the
beginning you know that he was
out of that class his Bat stood out big
time
um but yeah I got drafted in 09 get to
the big league in 14. yeah so tell me
about that that was that five years yeah
yeah roughly pouring some change right
tell me about your minor league
experience yeah because you're coming
you're from Puerto Rico right
and I'm assuming it's pretty similar to
the states
yeah I don't know it's uh and it's a
different culture though right different
culture uh Puerto Rico's
pretty Americanized when it comes to
certain things
um I got to go to Kissimmee Florida
which is okay an extended Township
from there yeah okay
uh so yeah my first year in GCL uh I
remember my first game we played in Port
St Lucie against the Mets that was my
professional debut and I hit three
ground balls back to the pitcher you
only have three of bets three bets and
uh but so what what like what happened
who'd you face do you know you remember
I don't remember I believe the last guy
I faced that game was Drew's Familia
um okay I'm pretty sure that was a
ground ball back to the picture but then
yeah I was 17 bro like you didn't know
what yeah like
kid throwing 90 in Puerto Rico is like
throwing fuel yeah you know so I get to
Pro Bowl and I'm all of a sudden facing
every single guy like
sitting 92 you know yeah and 92 was fast
yeah that time and I had three ground
balls back to the pitch right now I got
a two and a half hour drive back to
Kissimmee in full uni and all I can
think about is how I just went over
three with three ground Balls to the
picture did you think the world not the
world was going to end but you're like
dude at the time I was like I'm never
gonna get a hit yeah it felt like it was
the biggest game of my life and I was
like I flunked the test yeah so I called
my mom and I'm like hey you were right
I should have gone to college oh okay
like this is not it what college were
you going to uh so uh like he said at
the beginning of the show kids stay in
school take take classes seriously I
wasn't a very good student I had time
keeping up with what the teacher was
saying and then reading books I was not
very good at it so uh I wasn't
good enough student to go to a four-year
school okay so I I had to I had to
commit to ajuko to like have some
leverage for the draft so I was going to
go to Miami-Dade College at the time
they were number one in the nation so I
was like all right if it doesn't work
out on the draft we go there you know
ball out in Florida for a year yeah and
then win a championship and then get
drafted again I was in my head I'm like
I hope I don't have to go there like I
just want to play and uh
yeah I uh next day I got a hit and
everything was fine everything so you
and then you went through the mileage
tell me about your upper minor league
experience
um I went I went
rookie ball the next year I went short
season eight ball and then I went low I
next year I went double a high finishing
double A and then 13 I repeated double A
because I was only there a month the
year before I was 20. and I played that
year didn't go great it was my first
experience to like really struggling and
uh
I got to go back in 14 and uh
in 14 I had played before going to
spring training I had played in the
Caribbean World Series so I like
literally played all off season and
never stopped playing okay and the hell
I came back from the Caribbean World
Series like two weeks before spring
training and I went straight to spring
training and I I could never stop
playing so I was like in mid-season form
from day one in spring training and
killed spring training that year got to
start in double A again lasted two weeks
there and then I go to AAA and in AAA we
have an interim manager
uh Tom Lawless our manager Tony
DeFrancisco is currently away because
he's getting treated for cancer and
my first month or so I'm in AAA playing
for Tom Lawless who was the interim
manager and then
Tom Wallace's or uh Tony D is about to
make his comeback and you know how those
well we used to have those 11 A.M games
and miners the kids a bunch of SpongeBob
SquarePants songs and all that
we played one of those games and we
didn't know but Tony D was waiting for
us in the locker room
and we go in after the game and he's
like greeting everybody and
he goes hey you Puerto Rican you're a
good ball player
before anything and he goes how's your
English I was expecting hey nice to meet
you
you know it's like that was my English
this guy knows nothing about me huh
and I go into full key game mode and I
go English class English class very good
English class very good
so Tony D thinks I don't speak English
okay
he joins the team the next day and from
that day on for a full month
Tony D talks to me through a translator
um
hey so you you did this you you kept it
quiet for a month everybody knew but him
everybody knew but him so nobody took
the time to go tell him people on the
other team knew coaches on the other
teams know like
at the time my bat was like really like
starting to develop I'm like raking AAA
altuva's playing second for the ass okay
okay so yeah yeah I volunteered I told
them I was like hey man I can play
anywhere you want me to like I don't
need to play second base I just want to
be in the lineup like move me around I
started playing a different position
every single day literally like every
day a different position you told Tony
this no I told like like the team the
orientation so I got to AAA and that's
when I started moving around okay and
um
I would play infield and I would go talk
to the pitchers on the mountain and the
pictures are not Spanish speakers right
I'm speaking English by myself
is like just looking at the situation
happening
I don't know what he's thinking uh I
don't know if he's thinking I'm telling
hey man
you know I don't know what he's thinking
at the time yeah
but Gregorio Petit he was a veteran at
the time
um
he was like one day like he calls me in
the like one of those situations where
you're young and you make a mistake or
of an experience and like something and
he calls me in the office afterwards and
he's like hey I want to make sure like
this time like next time you do this you
do that like how we do like how what
would benefit you for the future so that
this mistake doesn't happen again
whatever something that happened on the
game in the game
and he called it's just the two of us
Patia and I and then him with in a
locked office and he's telling me all
this and we're sitting on a couch like
this and he is looking at me with that
same face you're looking at me right now
except he's telling me in Spanish he's
like [__] like you need to
[__] tell him I can't I can't do this
every single time
so petite was the he was the translator
he was he was a veteran guy you know
Venezuela and he's like translating and
he's like dude so you're all talking
about this yeah cause I can't hear you
and everything Tony's telling me right
here yeah but so it's not time to
translate so he so Tony was talking to
you Tony's talking to me and when he
talks and then it's time for petite to
translate but you understood and fatigue
wasn't translated well he wasn't
translating he was like I don't want to
do this yeah he's like bro I'm not as
good at it as you are like you can keep
it straight you should translate you
could have translated yeah he's like
you're keeping a straight face like I
can't I want to [__] die laughing
right now like I just don't I don't want
to be in this position I'm going to [__]
it up for the whole team okay and I'm
like no you got to keep going I decide
when it stops oh you told him that yeah
and then sure enough like a week later
the team is playing like [__] we are
getting our asses whooped three stair
games and he just calls every position
player in his office after a day game
and he is letting us have it for like 15
minutes straight just every cuss word in
the dictionary like every word you can
think of for 15 minutes straight the
door is locked it doesn't matter every
single person even if there were fans
they could hear us
and this dude is like every vein in his
neck and his face is popping out and
I just I raise my hand
and he goes what the [__] could you want
right now
and I'm like
I
I I just want to let you know that I
speak perfect English and the whole team
has been [__] with you this whole
time
in the middle in the middle of this
heated
argument that he is swearing us out did
you find anything no bro because I was
like this needs to stop like we've been
like he's at this point he's saying he
said this sentence three different times
doesn't have anything else to say I was
like I need a lot that's what I do I
lighten the mood you do like sometimes I
cross the line but it's fine but at this
time I was like hey this is the time and
I told them and he was so embarrassed
did everybody everybody's obviously
everybody's crying yeah and he is like I
okay
so so Tony will always be in your your
memories for that yes you still talk to
him how is he I haven't seen him that
many more that many more times after
that but he's still managing AAA he's
like a triple a legend man he's
he knows he uh he can be hard on players
but he knows how to get players right
yeah yeah so if I ever run into Tony I'm
gonna ask him about that yeah tell him
that Tony that Kiki's English is a lot
better now
you know English has gotten so much
better he was on my podcast
all right so I got this thing um
superlatives teammate superlatives
and uh
you know what they are who who would
have the
the worst smelling farts who has the
worst mind farts on the team what a
question
there's one answer to this there's one
answer and uh it's yeah I've said in
many outlets out there and he gets mad
every time but it's by far the goat both
pitching and farting clean Kershaw he he
smells horrible he does yeah and he
blames it on the greens
I don't know what it is does he blame it
on the greens now that's what he said so
back in the day he used to drink this
purple milkshake protein shake and he
was like preparing for it like he would
before the game he would eat a bunch of
milk and cookies and then during the
game he would just crushed this big old
protein shake purple thick thick and it
was all getting ready for the flight he
yeah see he he says he doesn't want to
but I think he loves it absolutely loves
it absolutely loves it he's like he
would be laying down he doesn't lay down
anymore he just stands up the whole
flight now but he will be laying down
and you haven't smelled it yet but you
can hear it you can see him like vibrate
because he was laughing so hard in
Secrets yeah yeah he knows every single
time he's dying laughing you know have
you seen his routine when he pitches I I
stay out of his way so when he's
pitching the only time I see him is when
he's laying on the dining table sleep on
the training table and he's like
pretending like he can't hear anybody
yeah he's watching his TV or laying down
taking a nap and
um
you know I made a goal of mine in my
early years we had a couple of arguments
we we uh discussions about it I thought
he wanted to fight me once because I
distracted him but um
yeah I always try to go in the trainer's
room and make him laugh during the start
day
and you could tell he he was getting a
little distracted his defense mechanism
was like he'd be he'd be there laying
super serious and you say something and
make him laugh and he's like
start going like this
and he's just started stretching his
hamstring uh that's his defense
mechanism
but he would be laying down on that
table and he just goes
and you just yeah nobody can see him
like nobody can see him laughing he just
starts searching his hammy but that uh
you know I missed a lot about La but one
of the things that I missed the most was
scene 22
on that table during the start days yeah
when you get to see it to me like
whenever for me you know as getting to
witness of Kershaw's greatness for a
room
many years now like that is one of the
things that's like I'm gonna take home
with me for the rest of my lives like 22
when 22 starting it's a special day it
is and it's been super dope I didn't
even what was crazy is when I was on the
other side I didn't even really know
Kershaw
you don't we didn't get to play play you
guys or anything so
and that wasn't like a baseball junkie
so
I was like Clayton Kershaw like I don't
he's good sure but I mean you know
whatever and then getting here to just
actually see it it's like oh now I know
and I didn't really get to see like
Prime Kershaw like you did so and he's
super dope to me so
you know to your point getting to see
him pitch every fifth day you know his
competitive competitive competitiveness
and all those uh attributes that he has
he's just uh super dope so let me get to
the next one so who has the worst taste
in music
on the team on our team
I'm gonna steer the pot and I'm going to
start big spoon David Peralta
[Laughter]
for those of you who don't know DP is
our team DJ so he's basically saying all
the music we listen to is trash
so let's let's hear what's why is
how does DP have the worst taste I mean
I mean yeah I've been I've been on the
team for three weeks but
to undp he's the worst DJ in the world
is a big Topic in our group chat yeah
um it is so I'm just I'm going to be a
good teammate and go with it the other
day the other day DP was uh he was on
the on the on this on the stick so I
call it on the sticks
and uh I think
for like an hour we listened to the same
five songs
and I don't think he realized it but he
was jamming he was loving it and I'm
like man somebody take the sticks away
from him so I may have to I ain't gonna
roll all the way with it but semi yeah
man you have to understand he's using an
iPod yeah he still has an iPod so his
iPod might have a five song capacity
yeah you're right that might be it right
but I have the regular iPod the one that
you uh isn't it the one that you scroll
I don't think it's that it's not old it
was small one yeah it's one of those
when the first touchscreens came out oh
the okay but uh yeah I have heard
multiple people complain about the same
five songs yep yeah I mean
it probably is in play that the iPod Pro
doesn't hold me into a fair point like
this doesn't bother me because I just 99
of the music I listen to is Spanish
music
but and that's why I've never been to
team DJ because I want everybody to be
able to like listen to what they want
and I know that like when it comes to
English music I'm not going to be the
best DJ so but I have heard
some of your countrymen complain about
the fact that why are we only listening
to Spanish music do you think it has
something it's got to be DP yeah I mean
yeah if you're going to be the DJs you
got to be
culturally flexible that's why I keep
everybody happy that's why I love when
Jay hey is on the sticks because he
mixes it up yeah he did the other at
dinner yeah it was nice yeah he had a
nice Vibe going he had some hip-hop and
then all of a sudden he spun me with
some like Bad Bunny and [__] I was like
okay yeah the steak is starting to taste
better now Jay knows how to do it okay
the next one who do you think
is the cheapest one on the team
the cheapest person on the team
I have my answer for this I know your
answer who's my answer uh
probably your designated hitter that is
my answer
I'm going to say CT because CT is
cheaper than JD CT is such a simple man
bro like I want to say he's still
driving the same truck he's been driving
since he got drafted Oh yeah then CT
don't he don't speak like it's not that
he's cheap he's just he just he just
didn't doesn't spend money JD JD
cheap I'm going cheap that's uh this
year we got him to split dinner with
Miggy Rowe
and that was asking a lot that was
active Congress
just for him to split dinner
and he doesn't want to like
any bets
those Florida taxes yeah you know they
they kill him yeah they kill him so he
tries to uh he save his money but yeah
I'm I'm gonna go I'm Gonna Roll with JD
even though he would save me what about
who is the most likely to have a a
burner account
on Instagram or Twitter or whatever
Austin Barnes I think it's barnsey too
I think it's Barnes or two and it's
strictly for him to stir
whatever pot that needs to be stirred
right he barnesley is an angry elf and
the way he releases his anger is by
steering the pot stirring the pot that's
yeah
and he's awesome I love Barnsley I love
him to death
I love him to death but that's what he
that's what he enjoys doing that's
that's his fun right stirring the pot is
fun for him and so we all have roles
within the clubhouse yep his is
the main pots there yeah yeah so if you
want something if you want a rumor
spread or
two guys you want a secret to be a
secret
don't tell Barnes yeah or he's or he
will he'll go around he won't say the
secret exactly but he'll stir the pot to
get you thinking about the secret you
know
but that's Barnes you that's what he
that's what he does is what we have fun
with you know that's absolutely that's
why we love him you know okay so what
about this
who has the dirtiest Locker
I haven't been around that long
um
but that that side of the locker room
where Julio Miggy
Jay hey those guys are
it's pretty full it gets Messier yeah
it's pretty full it gets a messy I'm not
gonna say it's dirty
but I'm gonna say there's not enough
room for all this stuff that's there I'm
gonna go with
my boy Lux
Lexi's not here
that's why his his Locker's been clean
because he's not here
because if his locker if he was here he
has shoes
outside you know
on the ground
he had a towel over here his pants or
his clothes are over here
some random stuff in the locker
he didn't know where anything is you
know that's that's Lux that is Lux I'm
glad to hear that nothing's changed yeah
no uh-uh I can't say it's worse than
before but it's definitely I wouldn't
say it's better
so G if you're watching this
um
I think I think you'd be doing us all
solid if you just
put your shoes up or something you know
you ain't got to do the whole thing
or you could do the whole thing whatever
you want to do but something you gotta
do something you know um so you got a
couple years to get better a couple
years ago couple years longer and you'll
get a bigger Locker yeah the bigger
Locker get another Locker that maybe the
he'll benefit from having two lockers
yeah if he messes up too long that's
if there was somebody that's going to do
it though it would be him
so we'll find out real soon see have you
ever done a Immaculate grid I have yeah
are you good at it depends on the day
okay well we'll see about today we're
about to do immaculate grid I am
really bad at him but I usually can get
like two to three answers after that you
can do the rest so the first one is Rich
Hill absolutely
well all right yeah I guess
I I go for the most obvious ones
yeah but you could have used them for
the A's too oh
yeah we could have A's in Boston uh Josh
Reddick
Josh Riddick did do that mm-hmm
Kinley Jansen for the bottom one mm-hmm
three percent that's good right yeah
rare
all right Cincinnati and Pittsburgh
Cincinnati in the A's
Cincinnati
Brave
Brave I don't know none of those
Cincinnati and Pittsburgh
yeah
I don't even know who man I don't even
know who played on
golly Cincinnati uh A's in Cincinnati is
Ramon Hernandez an answer for that
Asian Reds
is that easy Puerto Rican no Venezuelan
catcher
okay I hope I'm right
suspense is killing me is that does that
mean it's not an answer oh there you go
I don't even know who that guy is see
I'm such a minority Hernandez is the one
percent
um Pittsburgh and Cincinnati A's and
reds Adam Duvall I mean Atlanta and the
Reds oh yeah Adam Duvall did
he did huh I don't remember him on the
uh
Cincy yeah he came up with the Giants
and then got traded to the Reds
okay Pittsburgh and reds I don't even
know who played on Pittsburgh
I mean
you get one
Pittsburgh in the Reds
I got nothing Pittsburgh in 200k season
uh was Gary did he did Gary Cole do that
before
200 Francos you think he did right you
would think so but I don't know if he
did Ace 200 strikeout season I mean
Barry Zito yeah you could do Yankee go
Barry Zito
or Dave Stewart Dave Stewart uh did we
get it wrong the variety for uh
there it is
uh uh Brave Strider brush Strider yeah
for sure
yeah for sure Strider
all right
Pittsburgh in a 200k season
I mean I don't even know all the
pictures that came that pitched in
Pittsburgh
not get it
no because then we only have two we only
have two guesses though
you wanna try uh yeah I'm thinking you
think about the 200 strikeout season I'm
thinking about the who played for the
Reds and the Pirates
200 strikeouts from the Pittsburgh
Pirates
[Music]
I don't even know
I'm trying to look at remember all the
names around you see in the stadium
but I don't remember the names
I can only think of three pictures right
now from the Pirates yeah like Gary Cole
lyriano and Charlie Morton
Charlie Martin there was a singer bar
then he wouldn't throw 98 in
um
I don't think Liriano got to 200ks you
want to try gericho I guess we only got
one guess that is I mean I can't think
of a better game I'm Gonna Roll with
Gary Cole
we're going to roll a deer Cole
hello 84 right and we were guessing at
that like we were like worried about
that so this one's on you
yeah
Cincy in Pittsburgh I don't even I know
nothing about either one
Clemente didn't play for the Reds no he
didn't play for the Reds that was the
first thing I said but no he didn't play
for the Reds
um
their team is so young right now the
Reds both of them are available yeah
nobody it had to be somebody
kind of back in the day
and I don't know any I don't know any
history of either one of them
I mean we're talking who was in somebody
on a Big Red Machine that that played on
the Pirates too but I don't even know
who's on a Big Red Machine we didn't
have TVs in Puerto Rico yet so well you
don't either
oh
damn all right well
this has been fun
yeah um
there's a uh a button right there it
says give up yeah you want to hit it
buttons usually not an option yeah I
mean I'm cool with it because I ain't
made it this far
so to make it this far
I'm playing with house money
I'm gonna throw a Hail Mary
okay
Felix PA and you you spell that last
name like pie
Felix PA
this is a long shot
what are the what's what's the answer
yeah what is the answer
or the most common one I guess
do they show the answer on here yeah
I've never made it this far so I don't
know
262 possible answers we couldn't think
of one golly Dave Parker I wonder what
it is
I have no idea who that is Sonny Gray oh
I guess yeah well we did good we did
good eight out of nine we did good they
brought the closer in yeah I mean
I'm not the closer so yeah all right so
let's get to some fan questions real
quick before we wrap up bro all right
um
this is a really question this is just
because we didn't go to school
uh there are five Great Lakes
five five not four not four so but
there's four additional to this one
that's what yeah I was saying earlier
but you know we're Smart in other ways
yeah yeah you know
um Lake Superior
Lake Michigan that one's in Michigan
yeah I think that was there yeah Erie is
here right in Cleveland yeah Ontario
Canada I would think so it's definitely
not California not California and I
don't know what Huron Huron here in here
that one in Japan
where I'm Gonna Roll with Japan because
I don't know where Huron is uh but shout
out to uh
whoever for thank you for for giving us
yeah I appreciate the five Great Lakes
so
uh somebody asked me was LeBron the
biggest star to attend one of my games
I'm gonna say
no
I don't know who the biggest star is and
LeBron is huge
but you've been to many games where huge
stars have come who who have who has
come to games that you can think of as
maybe bigger than LeBron
yeah
I'm not sure if I want to answer your
question or ask a question to your
question whatever you want to do all
right
if we're going based off social media
then Cristiano Ronaldo
um but my question to your question is
at what point during our double header
did you get the script for the game
telling you that you were going to go
deep twice and you were going to salute
the king
so
sports are scripted by the way yeah that
that uh
that was cool man you know I didn't when
I when it kind of happened
as I was coming around third I was like
man
I gotta say something right it's cool
with this bobblehead night sick
bobblehead too sick bobble head and
um
I just looked up there man and and
saluted I don't I don't I don't know it
just kind of happened it kind of we were
all Witnesses yeah yeah it was it was a
super cool moment man I would say that's
probably top five
coolest moments you know with all the
irony that kind of happened it was for
me too and I wasn't even involved in it
yes I remember being in the Dugout and
everybody's like you just want to do it
for the second time and there were some
guys like
weird he just went deep twice and there
were some other guys who were like of
course he went deep twice with [__]
LeBron in half yeah I don't have
anything to do with LeBron but it was it
was it was uh really cool and having
LeBron there was a definitely definitely
something super dope yeah
um I got one more question do you feel
that La players have the same Vibe as
Red Sox players
um
I don't think that's a fair question
it's a different group I would say the
same thing in my my answer to my answer
to that is
players wise it's probably going to be
similar
like got dudes or dudes right
but
the market is what kind of changes guys
and not necessarily changes in For
Better or Worse it's just that Boston is
a different market like you have you're
under a microscope the whole time so
guys may not act as silly guys may not
um
I don't know just do
what dudes do
like they would if they were in
Pittsburgh or Baltimore or you know
Cleveland or somewhere like that right
and I think that's just
the difference is that the market is
kind of what shapes yeah I agree and
then I think like as far as Vibes like
the only thing that the fans get to see
is what happens that Dugout right and
Dodger Stadium Dugout is like five times
bigger than the one in Fenway Park is so
there is definitely not enough rooms for
shenanigans to happen at Fenway Park in
The Dugout at least right yep because
there's some weird [__] that happens in
the locker room a lot of weird stuff but
you know it's locker room stuff room to
stay there yeah I think we got one we do
have another question it snuck through
uh like a single so question for you
guys would you rather rob a homer to win
a World Series or hit a walk-off Homer
to win the WBC ooh
though both of those are dope my answer
would be Rob Homer to win the World
Series because the World Series is
why we play right but the WBC man golly
hitting a walk-off Homer in the WBC to
win it there may not be a better feeling
that's yeah um that's a really hard
question and
um
man I don't know
I think I think I have a lot more
highlights defensively than offensively
so let's just let's just say I'm gonna
hit a walk-off Homer to win the World
Series because there's a better chance
that I'm going to be at the plate in
that situation then there is a chance
that I'm going to be
in the Outfield because I can I play so
many different spots like being in that
situation at that time doesn't guarantee
me that I'm going to be out there even
though that's the question is already
there but I'm just making up excuses to
why I'm hitting a walk-off Homer to one
of those you see all right brother well
thank you for coming home man
um
I'm super glad you got to come on
especially was late notice
um you know cakes when we met in 20
it was kind of weird you know I was kind
of a
you can use standoffish or or whatever
word maybe kind of to myself
um
when I came over and you guys did
awesome right but I just didn't know how
to handle it all you know I had never
been
anywhere but Boston and you know meeting
a lot of new guys going to Arizona
everything was so new for me
um
but you and the crew man you guys uh
welcome me in even though it took me a
little time before I even practiced with
you guys I think it was like a week or
something before I even practiced with
y'all and so
um you know that meant the world uh to
me just to know that you know y'all were
uh just kind of waiting hanging out
chilling you know Mook will come holler
at us whenever he does and you guys uh
didn't act weird towards me didn't do
anything man so you welcomed me with
open arms and that meant the world to me
so thank you I'm glad you came back
um you're having fun playing really well
so I'm just uh super happy to to be with
you man and glad you uh brought some fun
you know same as you always do so
anyways man uh thank you for coming on
and we got a game later on so we got to
strap it in you ready I'm ready thanks
for having me of course take us to the
promised land again all right all right
guys that's a wrap with [__] Hernandez
and we'll see you guys later on
[Music]
thank you